So let's discuss the answer for our manufacturing cost
quiz. We had a watch processor that was one millimeter
square in size,and a laptop processor that is 100
millimeter squares in size. The question was, which of the
following is true? Is the cost of the laptop
processor about 100 times the cost of a watch processor?
Is it more than that or less than that?
We have seen already that if we disregard the yield,
the cost of a laptop processor would be about 100 times the cost of a watch
processor. Just because the same cost wafer gets
divided into 100 more of these than of these.
However, logic processors also result in lower yield.
So, this is why the cost of laptop processor
will be more than proportionately the cost of
the watch processor and this is the correct answer.